let's say I've got some basis B and it's
made up of K vectors let's say it's v1
v2 all the way to VK and let's say I
have some vector a and I know what a is
coordinate SAR with respect to B so this
is the coordinates of a with respect to
B are c1 c2 and I'm going to have K
coordinates because we have K basis
vectors or if this describes a subspace
this is a K dimensional subspace so I'm
going to have K of these guys right
there and all this means by our
definition of coordinates with respect
to a basis this literally means that I
can represent my vector a I can
represent my vector a as a linear
combination of these guys where these
coordinates are the weights so a would
be equal to c1 times v1 plus c2 times v2
plus all the way keep adding them up all
the way to CK times VK now another way
to write this another way to write this
is that let me write it this way if I
had a if I had a matrix where the column
vectors were the basis vectors of B so
let me write it just like that so let me
say I have some matrix C that looks like
this where its column vectors are just
these basis vectors so we have v1 v2 all
the way to VK if we assume that these
are let's say that all of these are a
member of RN then each of these are
going to have n entries or going to be
it's going to be an N N by K matrix each
of these guys have n entries so we're
gonna have n rows and we have K columns
so this let's imagine this matrix right
there another way to write this
expression right there is to say that a
is equal to a is equal to the vector c1
c2 all the way to CK multiple
by this matrix right there this would be
equal to a this would be equal to a this
statement over here and this expression
over here are completely identical if I
take this matrix vector product what do
I get I get c1 times v1 c1 times v1 plus
c2 times v2 plus c2 times v2 plus c3
times v3 all the way to CK times VK is
equal to a we've seen this multiple
times in multiple different contexts but
what's interesting here is this
expression is the same thing that's
really I'm just applying new words to
things that we've seen probably a
hundred times by now we can rewrite this
expression this is C and remember C is
just a matrix with our basis vectors as
columns C is equal to this guy this is
just the coordinates of a with respect
to the basis B so C times the vector
that has the coordinates of the vector a
with respect to the basis B that is
going to be equal to a that is equal to
a now why did I go through the trouble
of doing this because now you have a
fairly straightforward way if if I were
to give you this if I were to give you
that right there and say hey what is
what what is a if I wanted to write it
in in the standard in standard
coordinates or with respect to the
standard basis which is just kind of the
way we've been writing vectors all along
then you just multiply it times this
matrix C this matrix that has the basis
vectors as columns on it the other way
if you have some matrix a let's or sorry
if you have some vector a that you know
can be represented as a linear
combination of B or it's in the span of
this basis vectors then you could solve
for this guy right here to figure out a
coordinate with respect to V and so this
little matrix right here what does it do
it helps us change bases if you multiply
it times this guy you're going from the
vector represented by coordinates with
respect to some basis and you multiply
it times this guy you're going to get to
the vector and just the standard just
with standard coordinates so we call
this matrix right here chain
basis matrix change of basis change of
basis matrix which sounds very fancy but
all it literally is is a matrix with the
basis vectors as columns so let's just
apply this a little bit to see if we can
do anything
vaguely constructive with it let's say
that I have some basis let's say B for
basis let's say let's say I have two
vectors I'll define the vectors up here
let's say vector one is we're dealing
with r3 so vector 1 is 1 2 3 and let's
say that vector 2 vector 2 is vector 2
is 1 0 1 and let's say I'm going to
define some basis B as being the set of
the vectors V 1 and V 2 and you can
leave it to you to verify that these are
not linear combinations of each other so
this is a valid basis that you know
these aren't in any way linearly
dependent now let's say that I know some
vector that's in the span of these guys
let's say that I know some vector that's
in the span of these and all I know is
how it happens to be represented in
coordinates with respect to this basis
so let's say is I have some vector a and
when I represent the coordinates of a
with respect to this basis with respect
to this basis it's equal to I don't know
tate's
seven seven minus four so how can we
represent this guy in its standard
coordinates or you know how would we
what is a equal to what is a equal to
well you could just you know you say oh
well a is equal to seven times v1 minus
four times v2 and you would be
completely correct but let's actually
use this change of basis matrix that
I've introduced you to in this video so
the change of basis matrix here is going
to be is going to be just a matrix with
v1 and v2 as its columns so 1 2 3 and
then 1 0 1 and then if we multiply a
change of beta
basis matrix times the vector
representation with respect to that
basis so times 7 minus 4 7 7 minus 4
we're going to get the vector
represented in standard coordinates so
what is this going to be equal to what
is this we have a 3 by 2 matrix times a
2 by 1 we're going to get a 3 by 1
matrix which makes completely which
makes complete sense because we're
dealing in r3 we're dealing in r3 this
vector right here a is going to be a
member of r3 a is a member of r3 so when
we write it with standard coordinates we
should have three coordinates right
there now when we represented a with
respect to the basis we only had two
coordinates because a was in the plane
spanned by these two guys actually this
is good this is a good excuse to draw
this so let me draw it in three
dimensions let's say the span of v1 and
v2 looks like this the span of v1 v2
looks like this and this is the let's
say this is the zero vector right there
so this right here is the span span of
v1 and v2 or another way this is the
subspace that B is the basis for and so
we know that a is in this guy so let's
say v1 looks like this let's say v1
looks like this and that v2 I'm not even
looking at the numbers I'm just doing it
fairly abstract let's say v2 looks like
let's say v2 looks like this right here
now the fact that a can be represented
as a linear combination of v1 and v2
tells us that a is also going to be in
this plane in r3 and in fact it's seven
times v1 so seven times v1 so 2 1 V 1 to
V one's three ones
4 5 6 7 so it's 7 in that direction and
then it's a minus 4 in the v2 direction
so that's one in the v2 direction this
is minus one in the v2 direction minus 2
minus 3 minus 4 or we could do it here 1
2 3 4 so our vector a is going to look
like this it's going to look like this
going to sit on the plane it's going to
sit on the plane so this is our vector a
it's going to sit on the plane and when
we represent it with respect to this
basis when we represent as coordinates
with respect to our basis B we say ok
it's 7 of this guy
I didn't even I'm just doing this
abstract li don't pay attention to the
numbers just now I just want to
understand the idea we say it's 7 of
this guy minus 4 of this guy so it takes
you back here and you get this vector
which is in this plane so we only needed
two coordinates to specify it within
this plane because this subspace was
two-dimensional but we're dealing in r3
we're dealing in r3 and if we just want
the general version of a in standard
coordinates we'll have to essentially
get three coordinates three coordinates
and I want you understand that a is
sitting on this plane this plane just
keeps going on and on and on in all of
these directions a actually sits on that
plane it's a linear combination of that
guy in that guy but let's figure out
what a looks like in standard
coordinates in standard coordinates we
get the first term is going to be 1
times 7 plus 1 times minus 4 so that's
going to be 3 then you get 2 times 7
plus 0 times minus 4 that is 14 you get
3 times 7 plus 1 times minus 4 so 3
times 7 is 21 minus 4 is 17 so a is the
vector 314 17 that is equal to a now
let's say we wanted to go the other way
let's say we wanted to go the other way
let's say we have some vector and let me
pick a letter I haven't used recently
let's say I have some vector D let's say
so I have some vector D which is 8 8
minus 6 2 and let's say we know we know
that D D is a member of the span of the
span of our basis vectors the span of v1
and v2 v1 and v2 which tells us that D
can be represented as a linear
combination of these guys or that D is
in this subspace or that D can be
represented as coordinates with respect
to the basis B remember the basis B
the basis B was just equal to the set of
v1 and v2 that's all the basis B was now
we know we know that if we have our
change of basis matrix our change of
basis matrix x times the vector made up
of the coordinates of D with respect to
B so let me write that down D with
respect to B is equal to D we know that
we know if we have this guy's
coordinates and we multiply by the
change of basis matrix we'll just get
the the regular standard coordinate
representation representation of D now
in this case we have D we're given this
we of course know what the change of
basis matrix is so if we wanted to
represent D in coordinates with respect
to B we're going to have to solve this
equation so let's do that so our change
of basis matrix is 1 1 2 0 3 1 and we're
going to have to multiply it some times
some coordinates this thing right here
we can represent it as do it in yellow
we're going to represent it we're going
to need to cord it's going to be some
multiple of of v1 times plus some
multiple of V 2 so it's C 1 C 2 and we
know it has to be two coordinates
because this matrix vector product is
only well-defined if this is a member of
r2 right because this is a three by two
matrix we have two columns here so we
have to have two entries here and then
that's going to be equal to D that's
going to be equal to D so if 8-6 two and
so if we figure out what this vector is
we've figured out what the
representation or the coordinates of D
with respect to B are so let's solve
this let's solve this so to solve this
we can just set up an Augmented matrix
we can just set up an Augmented matrix
that's just our traditional way of
solving a linear equation so what we
have we have 1 1 2 0 3 1 we augment it
with this side right there so we have 8
minus 6 and 2 and let's keep my first
row the same
1 1 augmented it with 8 and let's
replace my second row let's replace my
second row with the second row minus 2
times the first row so I'm going to get
2 minus 2 times 1 is actually let me do
it the other way let me replace my
second row with 2 times my first row
minus my second row so 2 times 1 minus 2
is 0 2 times 1 minus 0 is 2 2 times 8 is
16 minus 6 is 10 now let's replace let's
replace the third row with 3 times the
first row minus the third row so 3 times
1 minus 3 is 0 3 times 1 minus 1 is 2
and then 3 times 8 3 times 8 is 24 minus
2 3 times 8 is 24 minus 2 is going to be
22 see it looks like I must have made a
mistake someplace because I have these
two would lead to no solution so let me
verify what I did make sure I didn't
make any strange errors so the second
row I replace it with 2 times the first
row minus the second row so 2 times 1
minus 2 is 0
2 times 1 minus 0 is 2 2 times 8 minus
minus 6 so there's my error that's equal
to 22 that was my error so these two
things are equivalent now let me let me
let me do I'll do one step at a time let
me divide let me let me replace my third
row with my third row minus my second
row just get it out of the way so I'll
keep this one one eight zero two twenty
two and then the third row is going to
be my third row I'm going to replace it
with my third row minus my second row so
it's going to be zero zero zero so that
just gets zeroed out now let me divide
my second row let me divide my second
row by two so I get 1 1 & 8 and then
this one becomes 0 1 and 11 and then of
course the third row is just a bunch of
0
and then let me keep my middle row the
same so it's 0 1 and 11 and then let me
replace my first row with my first row -
my middle row so 1 minus 0 is 1 1 minus
1 is 0 8 minus 11 is minus 3 and I'll
keep my last row the same so I've put
the left hand side in reduced row
echelon form so this right here is
essentially telling me my solution I
know that C 1 the solution so I can
write it this way I could write that 1 0
0 1 0 0 times C 1 C 2 is equal to is
equal to minus 3 11 0 or another way of
writing this is that 1 times C 1 plus 0
times C 2 or C 1 is equal to minus 3
right 1 times C 1 plus 0 times C 2 is
equal to minus 3 and then we could have
and then we have 0 times C 1 plus 1
times C 2 plus 1 times C 2 is going to
be equal to is going to be equal to 11
so our solution to this equation our
solution to this equation is is minus
311 or another way of saying this is
that if I wanted to write my vector D in
coordinates with respect to my basis B
it would be the coordinates through
minus 311 so if I want to write my
vector D in coordinates with respect
with respect to my basis B it's going to
be equal to minus 311 which implies
which implies we write it this way which
implies that D is equal to minus 3 times
vector 1 plus 11 times vector 2 and I'll
leave you I'll leave that for you to
verify but just like that using this
change of basis matrix we can go back
and forth if you have this
representation it's very easy to take
the product and get the standard
representation for D if you have the
standard representation or the
coordinates with respect to the standard
basis it's
easy well it's a little more involved
but then you just solve for your
coordinates with respect to the with
respect to be